Bertrand tu peux m'expliquer pourquoi on
a des palmes pour tourner la
bande-annonce de c'est ta voix Cannes
c'est la première fois de son histoire
que l'émission descend à Cannes donc il
faut frapper fort pour la bande-annonce
je pensais qu'on pouvait refaire
l'interview de Coluche par Michel
Denisot dans la piscine du Martinez
[Musique]
c'est une foire de la vanité
des choses comme on dit pour moi c'est
joli le festival du cinéma
[Musique]
et bah ça promet
l'usine a du racheté des machines
d'occasion
si je peux me permettre tu vois quand on
fait les travaux moi je travaille avec
Sophie depuis 15 ans il faut pas
réfléchir comme un pot de chambre
[Musique]
le poisson c'est pété
on a un problème quoi
j'ai fait un peu fou
je voulais péter mais c'est un liquide
qui est sorti
racontez-nous quel est le point de
départ excusez-moi je perds mon
oreillette oh elle est tombée c'est pas
grave
il fallait vraiment qu'elle soit au plus
proche de vous
le plus important c'était de l'avoir
directement dans mon salon
ces voitures sont littéralement dans son
appartement Elon Musk réussit beaucoup
beaucoup de choses mais pas tout et il a
de nouveau prouvé cette semaine en
posant la première pierre d'une
raffinerie de lithium ultra moderne au
Texas à cette occasion le grand boss est
arrivé en cyberprés et reparti avec pas
très loin à quelques encablures le
cybert truck a été repéré dans un fossé
dans la boue et visiblement impossible
de son exciré c'est le concept de la
tour Porsche du nom du célèbre fabricant
qui s'est associé au constructeur de
l'immeuble
un ascenseur monte votre voiture à votre
étage rien de moins
oui
j'aime bien oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et la France avec
évidemment la Zara
il s'appelle Jake ou encore Alfy et il
voudrait presque la vedette au chanteur
sur le compte Tik Tok officiel de
l'Eurovision à l'approche de la grande
finale ce weekend pas question d'oublier
les agents de sécurité à quatre pattes
c'est labradors et épagneul ont eu le
droit eux aussi à leur portrait officiel
bonjour Jacques vous êtes où
[Applaudissements]
Pascal dans un milieu que vous
connaissez parfaitement bien Laura
qu'elle a des plus grands rappeurs du
monde et je suis à la Cité Chevaleret
dans le 13e arrondissement
c'est publicité bon un peu agité mais
j'ai quelques officiers de sécurité
je voudrais dialoguer sans renvoyer la
balle impossible d'avancer sans ton
gilet par balle va donner les yeux les
yeux à la justice impossible de violer
cette femme pleine de vie
antisocial tu perds oui tu perds ton
sang froid repense à toutes ces années
ces années de sévices antisocial bientôt
les années de sévices enfin le temps
perdu qu'on ne rattrape plus c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je vais dans
une cité Pascal oui tout de suite
très très bien accueilli c'est comme ça
j'espère que je serais bien accueilli
pourquoi je ne serai pas bien église ça
me ferait très plaisir d'ailleurs de
faire une émission en direct et pourquoi
pas
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est que du vent ils ont parlé comme
d'une journée d'entraînement en vue de
Paris 2024 une journée pourtant au terme
de laquelle Teddy Riner est à nouveau
sur le toit du monde
comment
dans ce club de judo France il y a le
cours s'arrête le temps d'un instant
pour vivre en direct les exploits de
Lidl contre le russe tassewell comme une
leçon à distance je vous présente le
hoquet sous l'eau qui se joue en piscine
dans une piscine des championnats du
monde était organisés cette année-là les
règles sont les mêmes coquets un deux
buts avec des cages un palais qu'il faut
essayer de mettre de part et d'autre
mais attention cette fois les règles ont
un peu changé interdit de d'essayer de
d'enlever le style de son adversaire et
oui ne faites pas ça c'est tricher
comment ça va Agathe pourquoi
un peu pris du poids toi juste une
question parce que j'ai l'impression que
ta chemise
bon je suis franche ce matin sans filtre
j'ai décidé d'être nature peintures les
gars c'est un livre qui se moque de tous
les bouquins de développement personnel
je vais vous dire je reçois 15 par jour
à la radio je n'en peux plus des livres
de développement personnel toutes les
miss déjà en fond
oh [__] j'en peux plus des bouquins de
Miss je le dis il y en a pas ce soir
donc
comment vous énervez
ça monte d'un coup
tapez comme ça
[Rires]
non ce n'était pas un doigt d'honneur
non non c'est un geste culturel je vous
propose d'écouter la Zara qui était à
notre micro avec Nicolas Berri hier soir
donc je
un geste qui est négatif au contraire
c'est juste un geste déception qu'on
utilise entre amis
[Applaudissements]
space
tout le monde ne nous regarde pas tout
le monde ne nous déteste pas tout le
monde ne nous critique pas la vérité
c'est que tout le monde s'en fout